[Music]
our first question today is from jessica
in denver colorado
my question may sound silly and before i
ask it i want you to know that i get so
much value from your work but i
sometimes wonder why
why are you so compelled to help people
who are wired this way what is your
biggest challenge and what is your
biggest takeaway
i'm interested in the answer to this
question and jessica by the way i love
this question let me tell you why i love
the question because it's a difficult
question
i could make it sound easy there's a
narrative overlay where oh i want to
help people or or whatever but really
the question is the why
behind that you're in it for the money
well on the field
suck part
yeah i mean
that would be true if we just peppered
this whole thing with advertisements
um i'm not allergic to money either
though and so i don't want to renounce
that i don't even want to renounce
advertisements i'm just kind of grossed
out by them i am sponsored by bob's auto
mechanics today
so i'd be interested i'll give my sort
of narrative overlay of this whole thing
jessica because i know you're asking me
and ryan isn't here today but i'm
interested in some different answers
here so
i think we'll get a bit existential here
with peter in a moment but tk i thought
we would start with you why do you do
what you do are you
you help people you feel a desire to
create things that help people
why do you do what you do
one of the things i said last week when
we were talking about why
we decided to do this
is a principle that i govern my life by
when it comes to decision making and
that is in the absence of any logically
or morally compelling reason to do
otherwise
always do what feels good to you
always do what feels fun to you now
there are some logical reasons for why
something might feel fun and you say i'm
not going to do that there are some
morally compelling reasons for why
something might give you pleasure and
you say i'm not going to do that but in
the absence of that you do what brings
you joy and so for me
work like this helping people it's not
because i'm a saint it's not because one
day i was busy doing something else and
then the voice of god said
tk i want you to go podcast and help
people it was no i've always enjoyed
work that was like this even in a
different context i've always enjoyed
advocating for other people's
possibilities i've i've always you know
you know i've heard it said before that
one of the best ways to figure out what
makes you come alive is to figure out
what pisses you off what irritates you
what annoys you because that gives you
valuable information about what you're
hardwired to change the kinds of
problems you're likely to enjoy solving
and when i was a kid i always got
irritated when i saw someone who had
more possibilities than they believed in
and whenever i saw someone with a
self-defeating belief and living a life
where they were stressed out overwhelmed
sad all the time because they didn't see
the possibilities they had i always
enjoyed the game of trying to
convince them that they had the
permission and the power to be the
predominant creative force in their own
lives and so i'm playing that game i
enjoy doing this kind of work i'm not
convinced that like it's the only thing
that i could do or it's the one right
thing for me to do or that it's morally
good it's just it's what i enjoy it's
like playing basketball and playing the
piano pete i brought you on the podcast
a few months ago to talk about suffering
another joyous topic
and
what i've learned is that healing is
often at the terminus of suffering or
suffering can lead to
healing in some way and so i think if i
were to give a sort of
answer that
comports with how i feel today is it
feels good to see people heal and
sometimes when i create something
it helps someone heal their relationship
with their stuff their relationship with
their clinging their relationship with
other people their relationship with
money and healing those relationships
not fixing them not repairing them
but actually seeing that healing within
someone and it feels good for me so this
isn't completely altruistic either and i
want to be clear about that what i do
isn't oh i'm just serving the greater
good yes but it also feels good to serve
the greater good in some respect but i'm
interested why do you do what you do
because you're a a radical theologian
you're a philosopher and you sometimes
share some things that are considered to
be controversial and it seems to me to
be easier to just not share those things
at all yes oh yeah that's a good
question i was first of all thinking
what do i do
and then after then why do i do it um
but you've said it very well actually i
have to write that down next time
someone asked me what i do
radical theologian philosopher
you know i was reminded there's a of a
story of a guy who um goes on a sea
voyage and he washes up on this uh shore
and he goes into this town and he starts
to preach and he preaches this message
and at first lots of people listen to
him but after he's been there for a few
months he becomes you know pretty new
and people stop paying attention but
still this guy keeps preaching his
message and eventually someone comes up
to him and says you know like no one's
listening to you why do you keep singing
this song why do you keep preaching this
message when it's obvious that nobody
really is paying attention
and he said
well at first i thought i was doing it
for the people but he said then i
realized that the message i preach is
for myself
and that's kind of how i feel about a
lot of our work is that our work is
often a way of self-healing uh you know
reminding ourselves of something or
speaking to some dimension of ourselves
so for example if i'm always talking
about how to embrace
lack how to kind of like uh
get free from frenetic pursuits of kind
of whatever i go like well maybe i'm the
i'm the the person who needs to receive
the message just like if you write a
love letter
uh often you don't even have to send it
because you think you're writing it for
somebody else but you're really writing
it for yourself so and even if you do
send it you probably read it 10 times 20
times the other person might read it
once
because the love letter always likan
says reaches its destination because its
destination is not the other as such but
but in a sense it's yourself
it's beautiful i so good i think about
i teach a writing class how to write
better.org it's an online writing class
and what i learned i started teaching
that a decade ago back in 2012 and i
noticed especially the first two or
three years my writing improved
dramatically from teaching the writing
class because in a way i was i was
beginning to i had to pause it's like a
baker who bakes a cake and they don't
know how they do it if they need to give
someone else the recipe they have to
stop and say i need this much flour i
need to do it in this sequence i need to
bake it at this temperature this much
sugar this much chocolate goes into the
cake but they may not know that before
and what they do is they start to refine
it based on the experience of actually
teaching that to someone else so in a
way
by teaching this to other people i think
the person that has improved and healed
most is me yes and if other people go
out there and they i've noticed that
people tend to share
what we do on the podcast that's why we
we do all of these tick tock clips and
instagram clips is because as you start
to share something do we have to do some
dance tech talks
it's gonna be great okay all right
you're going to have to teach me the
moves because i watch a lot of them but
i'm not very good at them so
wait till the end of this you're going
to look great
we're going to remix just that moment
right there
anyway jessica i'd love to send you a
copy of our book love people use things
it's about healing the seven essential
relationships in our lives ryan and i
wrote this uh what we finished it during
the pandemic and what i realized in a
way this was a pandemic preparation
manual
but in the sense that we are going
through our own individual pandemics we
have all of these tragedies with our
finances so healing the relationship
with our money healing our relationship
with our values with our self
with other people with our stuff and so
i'd love to send you a audio book
version if you like our podcast you'll
enjoy the audio book of love people use
things or if you want the book book or
the ebook be happy to send those to you
as well jessica alabama will reach out
to you and get you a copy of that book
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free